we have this from valuetainment.com
check this out Patrick Bet David offers
Tucker Carlson 100 million dollars it's
a lot of money dude actually it's 25 mil
it's 20 million dollars a year over five
years so this is uh the value payment
podcast is offering took across a 100
million dollar contract I'm gonna be
honest I kind of feel like it's just a
stunt I mean I'm sure it's a legitimate
offer but I'm also confident that
Patrick Bet David and the value Tammy
people know there's no way Tucker would
take this deep why would he there's no
reason he's going to launch his own
thing and he's going to make a billion
dollars so there's just no reason for a
deal like this but you can see just how
valuable people consider Tucker Carlson
and Fox News oh boy
Rumble hasn't tried yet they probably
did yeah behind the scenes but what what
would an independent launch room Tucker
look like is he gonna go on Rumble is
going to go on YouTube like where do you
literally facilitate his own website his
own website I am here to announce that
Tim cast is going to make an offer to
Carlson of uh 100 000 per year to work
full time time because we can't afford a
hundred million dollars that's the best
we can do come on Tucker it's worth it
yeah you can hang out here with Seamus
yeah how much fun
glass bottled water but they're worth it
so uh Patrick David offered Tucker
Carlson 100 million dollars for five
years an equity stake in valuetainment
president of valuetainment and a board
seat to project your strategic vision
and voice your own podcast and other
daily weekly shows documentaries and
movies covering topics you care about
what else we are all ears our conviction
about Freedom Liberty and Truth Run Deep
We believe We are the absolute right fit
for you in America and I think they're
in Florida too so maybe they're there
there could be something happening here
maybe maybe this is is not so much a PR
stunt as it is they've already made a
deal oh I just feel like we saw earlier
this year when people were discussing
their contracts out loud and lots of
drama yeah he's gonna say what if Tucker
publishes the contract Chuck is like
they gave me this contract that says
they're only going to give me 100
million dollars over four years I can
make way more money than that but that
includes all of my staff which get paid
a lot of money it also includes
production costs because we like to make
skits it's gonna be a lot I love
Tucker's kids
I mean I I have said for a while that I
think there will be a big push from
mainstream media Outlets that are trying
to compete with Fox to try and get
Tucker Carlson on the show I don't know
I mean after years he was on Fox for
like what over a decade he's been doing
Newsmax well his show is only was only
what six years but he was he was like on
the circuit beforehand he was doing
mainstream television appearances for a
long time I wonder and you can probably
speak to this better than I can Tim but
transitioning to being fully independent
with in-house Pro production as opposed
to having a company to fall back on like
there is that isn't just something you
do overnight not everyone is cut out to
to make that change and I wonder if
there is a comfort and sort of staying
with a medium that you know I mean I
would imagine being under contract is a
lot more comfortable than just doing
your own thing
um I mean but you saw how I mean his
video on Twitter when he released a
statement the amount of views that that
racked up I mean he I'm pretty sure he
broke his viewership live compared to
what he normally has done on Fox 20
times yeah the viewership I think I mean
that that would be cool to see is an
integration into Twitter or something
along those lines the the Twitter video
is different from his show
because I was saying this before his
show gets 3.3 million on average but not
everybody watches every single episode
of took a Crossing tonight yeah so if
you watch three episodes per month if
the average person only watches let's
let's say they watch five episodes that
means there's actually four times many
unique viewers because they're only
watching One in five episodes and he's
got you know he's already one in four
episodes because he does you know once
uh once a day every every week
and that means that if you were to take
all of his viewers and have them watch
one video you'd get 60 million you get
70 million or whatever so I don't know
if it correlates properly and also the
people who watch the video included
leftists who've never seen a show before
exactly well and also if I mean say like
he would take like the Twitter route or
anything like that is the Boomers no
boomers are going to see it I mean I
feel like that's the majority of people
that actually watched his show too is
the older generations and that's gonna
basically completely cut off their
access I mean I'm pretty sure Fox News
lost like what half of their viewers uh
just from after they fired him so you're
already seeing the kind of shift In
Their audience yeah exactly well that's
part of what's so sad about the whole
situation everyone keeps talking about
how Duggar's going to be better off
without Fox and they're probably right
in terms of how much he's going to
happen
but yeah he he was very important at Fox
and there are a lot of people who just
are not gonna know where to find him
unfortunately or or won't discover him
in the first place he's the only
populist they had so I mean maybe this
is more about 2024 than anything well
that's what I'm I was thinking is what
if because I I thought I saw it had seen
something about Rupert Murdoch you know
negotiating a new contract with him and
him still actually being under that
contract I'm not sure how accurate that
is but I mean in doing so he's basically
gagged I mean he can't sign any other
contract from what I'm aware of it's
like if you shut Tucker Carlson down
during election season that's when he's
the most effective in my mind if I'm the
enemy and I'm trying to silence and
de-platform Tucker Carlson you guys saw
the AOC video deep platforming works you
know you do it right before election
season when he has the most power and
the most momentum and he can and the
primaries are coming up and who is the
stalker supporting
I'm not even totally sure yeah good
question I mean obviously it's gonna be
a republican so that's all right I would
imagine he's going to support whoever
the I mean the lead Runner is I think
because I mean you got a probably
DeSantis V Trump I would assume he's
probably gonna support Trump just
because he has I think a higher chance
of winning and becoming the nominee but
I mean regardless of whoever the nominee
is he's obviously going to support the
Republican candidate yeah no question
yeah who is supposed to fill his slot
like what's happening with the eight
o'clock oh they picked somebody didn't
they well yeah everyone was ripping on
him yeah he posted and got ratio to like
absolutely it must be so significant
that I have definitely are definitely
aware of it that was the hardest thing
about watching all this like what is
fox's plan there is no Lawrence Jones I
don't even know who that is
uh bongino too bongino left a couple
weeks ago they couldn't uh negotiate a
contract so if you I loved that the day
when Tucker was released and Don Lemon
was released at the same time too nobody
was talking about the CNN contractor
about Don Lemon it was all Tucker
and everyone was speculating about
Tucker Carlson why would they be getting
rid of him What story did we cover and
that upset them where is he going he's
so important and with Don Lemon was like
yeah Don Lemon did all that really
important journalistic work that exposed
powerful people it was like yeah no he
didn't ever since that like misogynistic
clip from Don Lemon which wasn't
misogynistic at all I think he made it
like a light-hearted joke he said women
are not in their Prime in their 50s oh
yeah oh whoa I remember he got in
trouble from that and then that was like
the last controversy he had uh that is
awesome that that is he said something
like if you look online it's like 20 30s
or 40s women in her 50s are not in their
Prime when he's talking about men in
their Prime too and the difference but
she was like what is the the other one
was like what does that mean like
childbirthing like is that what you're
talking about and he's like I'm just
saying Google it and then when you
Googled it it was the funniest thing
it's like women are in their Prime in
their 40s and 50s and it's like that's
hilarious folks found out right you're
like fact check false yeah pants on fire
human beings are in their Prime in their
20s like anybody else early 30s
especially yeah there's a lot of push
for women saying like oh you're in your
Prime in your 40s because you're more
confident and stuff like that like I
would argue that like depends on what
we're evaluating here right like a woman
in her 40s is not in her prime to Bear
children I was gonna say I don't think
you're in your Prime that you're going
through I mean you're in your Prime like
you're feeling good about yourself and
you're more accomplished and maybe
you're more economically established
like I could see that argument it just
depends on what your your metrics are
that's what I don't like about these
generalizations maybe maybe that was
very argument they're making is that
when women can no longer have kids
they're now in their Prime to work and
be CEOs exactly but for real human
beings or utilities right and depending
on which part of the culture you're
standing uh on and looking at them from
their other sexual utility or an
economics they're not a person
well yeah we're gonna have those baby
pods we saw those baby pods right baby
little baby factories yeah the baby yeah
the viral video where it's like we will
gestate humans and pots I thought that
was like the new politically correct
term for birthing person baby factories
baby Factory no no it's not well that's
offensive it's baby Factory it's not
it's not it's it's not woman it's
birthing person it's like it's like the
new term for uh young mother's homes you
know where they used to like send girls
who got pregnant but it's just like
birthing factors collector baby here a
game that just came out like dark souls
or something came out and that everybody
was excited held in a ring Alden ring
yeah which is basically Dark Souls and
when you when you're making your
character you can't choose male or
female you can choose type one or type
two like it's diabetes it was something
it was a or b or something it was like
no it was like body type choose your
body type and it's like clearly male and
female but it didn't say male and female
and it's just like what what is it well
and it's funny because in those games
usually you can make like really
distorted looking characters like like
Skyrim and those kind of like just that
genre of games usually you can just make
the characters however you want but it
seems like they're moving away from that
and that was like the biggest part of
those games was like creating a sweet
like woman that was an orc but looked
like a man and now you just can't do any
of it well the Harry Potter game is
actually really funny because you can
you can customize your character to a
crazy degree like you can make a big
super masculine guy but has a voice of a
little girl or you can make it's almost
like Bob's Burgers or uh Venture
Brothers you can make like a small
female character who talks like this and
then and then you could make a male
character who's in the girls dorm or a
female character in the boys dorm it's
just like I remember they had like but
the game but the character in the game
but they're saying it's transphobic but
doesn't even make sense in Harry Potter
they'd be a trans character they can eat
drink magic potion
now I am it's magic there you go so
there's got to be a cycle forever the
puberty blocker potion and the yeah but
they don't need that they have matched
puberty block Oso yeah and you're good
like you can literally turn yourself
into fertilities
ruin your life I'm the compassionate one
there was that Bud Light spell get that
extra estrogen there would be no furries
in Harry Potter because they would just
literally turn into animals so hold on
are all the people in Harry Potter who
turn into animals furries that is a hot
take over there yeah that's true I mean
that was that was the whole theme of the
third book that the one dude was a
werewolf so the other three friends
would turn into animals to hang out with
them or whatever because like werewolf
wouldn't attack animal people or
something like that yeah I wasn't uh I
wasn't allowed to read Harry Potter
because if someone raised in a
traditional home my parents didn't want
me to be a nerd
I'm sad for you missed a huge part of
culture this is a gigantic nerd you
missed out yeah
how do you interpret the leftist
arguments in philosophy if you don't
know anything about Harry Potter I
haven't read the foundational Theory
yeah I don't read Theory Trump is
Voldemort don't you know what that means
that's actually true but actually you
can't connect with any of the the young
people basically any of your peers make
them interested in Catholicism if you
can't put it in terms of Harry Potter
here's here's the secret Hannah Claire
they can't connect with each other
either because of what this culture's
done yeah but you're not reaching them
either so
look I'm not reaching them with
witchcraft and Magic
so what's your plan
to use the power of reason and cracks
and logic and cartoons and yes
absolutely well placed jokes here and
there until you do it did you ever feel
like you missed out though because you
can read Harry Potter no I'm kidding I
was not not well my parents like frowned
upon it but they were never like ah wow
Harry Potter it's not as bad as like not
having watched Fast and the Furious you
know what I mean no oh of course every
Christmas we watched all of those things
classic tradition we watch Fast and
Furious and you got 10 movies so you're
what you're all day it's on the TV and
you know the the people are making dip
and the families coming in and they're
wearing the fancy sweaters yeah and then
everyone quotes the movie because they
all know the words
I actually I actually didn't watch Fast
and Furious as a kid either I you know
you know when I saw Fast and Furious for
the first time I was on a Greyhound bus
and there was this woman a few seats
across from me and she turns to me she's
like do you want to watch Fast and
Furious I was like yeah that sounds like
such a greyhound that's true and then
she she sat next to me with her laptop
and she popped it open and I was like
she's like these movies are they say
they're about cars it's really about
family and she started playing it and I
was like I believe you I was I'm dude
I'm not kidding it's actually happened I
was like and I was watching I was like
this film is about bam I was like shut
up no this actually happened but this
actually happened this is a real story
this is not a deep fake this literally
happened I watched Fast and Furious on a
Greyhound for the first time
this very sweet young woman wanted
someone to watch Fast and Furious with
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time